the world Stood Still with unbreakable
silence but the faith of our fans still
pierced through our skylines patiently
we wait for our screams to take flight
for symphonies of buzzer-beaters to make
the melody of our souls we wrap our
cities teams planted on our chest like a
breastplate of righteousness flocks of
fans begging to hear the swiss melodic
be blood into the veins
we long for threes shots raining like
hurricane of glory a leaves that fly
like confetti and camaraderie that tells
our storm and a strong fandom
interruption of joy is white garbage
watch how we rise together how we ascend
past the fear take flight past the hate
our love for the game intact alive and
true our swag is fly as ever is still
powerful strong and new
[Music]
we keep marching and movie break down
these institutions so past the rock so
we can slam-dunk this level can you hear
it the anthem of are you see the
monsters of our pavement the cadence of
the dribble pounding until the day ends
a love that unites ignites a flame
unkilled with spark illuminating
everything for our game our embers in
the dark
you